they are good the 4H hour 50 ma that's
the level guys that's the level look at
this okay this what we were talking in
justest this video
450ma it's our main support at the
moment the key and most important level
in the chart because if we break this
level and test it as resistance for two
candles then it's very likely that we
start to drop all way towards 50 50k all
right so right now that's what I'm
looking at all I'm looking at is the 4H
hour 50 and it's true that yesterday we
were left uh without a trade um I was
telling you guys that for me to enter a
short I would like to see then two
candlesticks closing and testing a
resistance the four or 50 ma that is not
the case and I explained this very
carefully yesterday because this
Candlestick is is true that it closed
below the 4 or 50a but I was telling you
that I would like to see this
Candlestick and the next one closing
below the 4H hour 50 and testing it a
resistance because if that was the case
then that would mean that the next
Candlestick would have a lot of risk to
the downside now you can see how instead
of doing that we actually recover the 4H
hour 50a testing it a support and then
you have that candle to the upside now
again down testing it as support so it's
kind of a game of what is going to
happen with this level are we going to
keep testing it as a support because if
that's the case you can see that the 40
50 May keeps going up okay and that
could be at the end a very strong
support along with the range lows that
could push price back up to the range
highs or even again towards this level
here 53,000 okay that's a possibility
but the other possibility and that is to
me uh the safest trate would be what I
explained yesterday it can still happen
right drop below this level tested a
resistance and I told you yesterday two
c candlesticks please two candlesticks
testing it as resistance one two then
the third one it has a lot of risk to
the downside maybe doesn't happen in the
third one happens in the fourth one but
from the third one the race to the
downside is much higher all right and
then we can see this so that's what I'm
looking at I'm looking at the 450 are we
going to drop below it are we going to
go above it but when you see price
action that it's a bit choppy like this
look you can see a lot of weeks like
this okay we're seeing loads of weeks um
loads of fake outs look at this you lose
the 4 or 50a you recover it you mean you
have to be very careful and that's what
I was telling you yesterday don't enter
short yet only enter a short if you see
confirmation confirmation is two
candlesticks testing the resistance all
right you didn't test the resistance
here not even once because this
Candlestick lost a level and the next
one didn't test a resistance it went at
the end above it okay and then the next
one tested a support but you need a
confirmation and here you have an
example okay this is the work that I'm
doing this is Henry Henry is telling me
thank thankfully I saw your video
yesterday was convinced to short but
your video basically asked me to be more
patient and wait for two candles below
the EMA and invalidated my short entry
uh so that's what I mean okay it's not
only about taking the right trades is
also about not taking the wrong
traits Capital preservation and you
probably this many times and perhaps
it's not something that you really take
into consideration because you are only
thinking about making money making money
and that's fine but what's the point of
making money then you lose it you have
to make money at the same time as you
are keeping it safe okay that's when I
come to the Chart I only look for high
probability trades this was not a high
probability trade a high prob trade is
closing below this level and then two
candlesticks close testing at the
resistance
that is to me a high prity rate because
the chances for price to drop towards
this liquidity pool or 50,000 yesterday
at the end we said that 50,000 better
than this liquidity pool because it's a
psychological level where we can see
some manipulation the same as with it
here okay that could happen now in the
opposite direction of 50,000 so that's
what I mean you have to be very careful
with your entries all right clear entry
clear invalidation if if do your entry
trigger doesn't happen as you want it
then forget about it okay uh that's the
way to trade at least in my opinion now
I would like to take you to the
liquidation levels of high of high block
capital and the liquidation hit map and
try to make some sense of what it's
currently going on there liquidation
levels let's have a look Delta I imagine
is back to zero uh $3 billion worth of
sh liquidations again take this amount
and this number with a pin of sold
because it's not real okay there are not
$3 billion worth of short liquidations
use it as a reference I'm using the max
liquidity setting so this number is not
real don't worry so to me $3 billion is
basically neutral okay in this setting
that's basically neutral and not much
interest I think that this number could
be interesting if it's uh when it's
between 20 and 30 billion that's when it
gets interesting okay but 3 billion nah
that's neutral to me now what I find
quite interesting about the liquidation
levels is that it's true that I can see
some spikes in the right of
liquidations at
50,000 you can check here 20 127 Million
worth of sh liquidations of
5073 that's interesting but I can see
the same to the upside and even more
liquidations I have one here look
52,700 another one here this quite high
up that
54,000
this one 53,3 69 you mean you have to be
careful because there is qu of liquidity
to the upsite and if we go into the
liquidation hit map I imagine that it is
going to show up some liquidity around
those levels too there you go it's so
very clear at the moment because it's
true that what I see in the chart is
there is a lot of liquidity between
50,500 and 50,000
uh if we enter the Z of
50,500 I imagine that will drop directly
to 50,000 so 50,000 is the number that
I'm going to pay attention to not this
one here and it's true that there is a
lot of liquidity there and if you notice
guys try to ignore what happens here
look try to watch until here okay what
do you see here guys at this point you
already see that there is some liquidity
there a 50,000 and
50,400 right you see that there is some
liquidity there but I want you to to
look at something
here what
happens later is to me the most
interesting part this Spike here a
50,500 look at that Spike do you see
what it does that spike is not attacking
the area that we knew
already look at this
please this spike is not attacking the
area that we could already see from this
level because you already can see that
50,400 and 50,50 there is a lot of
liquidity and it doesn't go the way
there it stops at
50550 okay it stops $100 before getting
there and then it bounces why well
usually the only way to describe this is
a room for liquidity a room for
liquidity in terms that price doesn't
attack these areas and leave them
untouched on purpose so the liquidity
isay stays there but it doesn't only
stay there it actually increases because
then when the market make it pushes
price back up that's the room for
liquidity because there are going to be
some ret traders that are going to think
okay price is going up I'm going to open
a long because maybe we get back inside
the range and then price can go to the
top of the range again those Traders are
going to be opening Longs and if they're
using High Leverage The requisition are
going to accumulate in this areas that's
why you see this yellow bar and this
yellow bar here increasing now I want
you to think about something okay do
this kind of exercise when was it more
worth it for the market maker to talk
these numbers 50 50,400 and 50,000 when
is it more worth it to do this to to go
to this levels now or back here 20
February 535 UTC time well to me the
answer is clear now there was there
should be more intention and is more
worth it to attack these numbers because
the liquidity around these levels have
increased a lot because this week here
didn't go there and then from there
price went up when a lot of retail
Traders jump on the boat on their Longs
and their liquidations is stacked and
accumulated around this level so to me
this looks like a run for liquidity and
it's telling me that it's very possible
that we go all the way to 50,000 when we
have that liquidity pool which matches
with liquidation levels it's not an
accident that's what liquidity pools are
and also 50,000 is a psychological
level so uh that's all I have to say
about this chart is supporting the idea
of 50,000 yes I you can say yes but we
see a also a yellow bar at 53,1
15 all right that's true we could go
there why not
but understanding the psychology of this
Mia that it was likely a room for
liquidity
that is telling me that at this exact
point they knew what they were doing
they knew that they were going to push
price up so the retail Trader goes long
the liquidity increases here and then
they can drop price all the way to
50,000 so to me makes more sense that
the market maker was already planning
from yesterday to do all this move to
then hit this amount of liquidations
that was going to be a lot bigger all
right so to me it would make more sense
50,000 first and then we'll see what
happens if you start to see the market
maker building long that area then we
can look at
53,1 15 all right that's what I think I
think that also not to say that we are
closer to these levels to the downside
okay so it's more likely that we go fast
to 50,000 instead of 53,000 that is what
I think but the chart has to support
that theory and that's why we are
looking at the 4H hour 50 Ma I want to
explain you this well because you have
to look beyond the yellow bars all right
you don't many traders that are looking
at these Maps now because uh they're
getting popular this liquidation hit
Maps they still don't know how to read
them and they see this chart and they
see okay jell bars I see a Jello bar at
50,000 and a jell bar at 50 3,000 but
it's not about the yellow bars it's
about the movement around those yellow
bars and how they get more liquidity in
them all right and this kind of moves
this kind of potential rules for
liquidity is why Mak more sense okay
that's what the logic is you have to try
to find some logic into your charts if
you know they are just charts okay not
projection so um be very careful we're
going to go back into the into the chat
right now I'm going to um share my final
thoughts about this and how I'm going to
trade this but I think here we must be
patient let's have a very quick look at
the book before going into the chart and
to be honest it's looking quite messy I
mean you have some red bars to the
upside also to the downside so it's not
very clear where they want to get to is
you don't really know what the target is
right so it's not telling us much
information now what I can see though is
this red bar below current the current
uh price value but if you notice it was
previously at
,700 but then there is a cut in the
graph and he escalates a $100 higher can
you see the Red Bar going from ,700 to
50,800 now okay what does this mean in
my opinion it means two things it can be
one of those two things the first thing
is that if we continue seeing this red
bar escalating higher you have to try to
imagine it as a trailer stop loss that
it's a as it's it's increasing it's
going up as price goes up so that's
going to tell you that the most likely
outcome is that price continues going up
the other alternative is that they might
get ready to do some spoofing okay and
you are going to notice with this is
that this uh Red Bar is quite volatile
in the way that they are moving it from
one price to the next and that means
that perhaps if price is going to go now
towards the level that would be A500
drop $500 drop from here but if we get a
drop and we are about to touch that red
bar you have to be very careful because
they might do a spoofing with our red
bar I mean spoofing is when the price is
about to touch all those order
and right before it happens a few
minutes before it happens that rate bar
disappears out of the chart and then
price drops lower why do they do that
because they know that some Traders are
trading based on their book and they
think that that could be a bu wall an
area in the chart a level in the chart
where there are many buy orders from the
retail Trader and if price goes all the
way there and hits the area then they're
going to see a big bounds so the retail
Trader places their orders the buy
orders in that red bar now if if those
orders start from the market maker and
that would explain why it's moving like
that then the market maker could spoof
in those orders they could make them
disappear right before hitting them
making the retail Trader believe or
tricking them that they were going to
hit that zone to bounce but what they do
instead is removing all those orders
right before and then price continues
dropping all right so uh be very careful
with it do you want to see the Red Bar
continue mov been higher maybe then to
51,000 and then yes that can tell you
the price is willing to continue going
higher now if price goes to that red but
I would be very cautious very cautious
that they're not going to do some kind
of spoofing there right so uh that's
what I mean just because you see a a red
bar doesn't mean that it's a bu wall
that's something that you have to try to
understand okay so um that's my read of
the other book let let's go to the to
the Chart because this video is going to
get too long otherwise back to the Chart
I'm going to be very quickly I'm going
to wrap this up so I'm going to Mark the
two main interest levels in the chart
the first one is going to be this um
50,000 level it's a psychological level
also you can see that it's a part of
this liquidity pool almost the 100%
retra it was also an area where we saw
previously s manipulation so you have to
keep an eye on this level now of course
the other level would be and to be the
main level where everything is playing
out is the 4H hour 50 and then the range
size so how what they want to say with
this well you have a short scenario that
to me is the is the scenario that I
would feel most comfortable trading
because I know that if if it happens
then I'm going to have a lot of
conviction that it's going to play out
and that would be a drop below the 4 R50
CMA then I want to see two candlesticks
testing it as resistance so that will be
one and then two and then that's when I
would enter short after this Candlestick
close is testing it as resistance and
closing below it because from the third
candles onwards the risk to the downside
would increase very fast okay so maybe
you can see something like this and a
drop to 50,000 that would be the the
setup that I would feel more conviction
with but for that I need first these two
candlesticks testing it as resistance
and one Candlestick first closing below
the level so that would
require three 4 hours Candlestick so
that would be uh 12 hours that would
require 12 hours of setup okay perhaps
during the asent session that could
match right now the other is the longe
scenario and for the longe scenario the
level that I like is uh 53,1 15 because
that's what we saw this liquidation
levels in the hit map okay and for that
to happen then what I want to see is
pretty much what I'm seeing in the chart
I can see the 4our 50 m being the
current support and it's shwing up like
a very strong support I would like to
see the 4H hour 50 may continue creeping
upwards until the range highs some more
consolidation here then you have here
double support and that would be telling
me okay you know what we've been testing
that support we're not breaking below it
so we could see some continuation up and
hit those liquidations after that well
we'll have to see the reaction from the
level okay because if we start to see
some consolidation around this level
that will be telling you to favor of
site however this could be a three Taps
pattern 1 2 three drop all right but for
that first we need to see the reaction
of the price action around that level if
we see consolidation
we're going to favor higher prices if we
see a drop back inside the range inside
the range highs like this then we enter
a short here all right so that's what
I'm going to play out the main thing is
to have patience okay I know my setups I
know what I'm looking for so I just have
to be patient and today is
Thursday that means that I have two more
trading days today and tomorrow it seems
that today I'm not going to be on a
trade perhaps during the a session yes
if I see that move here okay if not I'll
just be patient and wait and see what
happens tomorrow if tomorrow the 4 50 ma
is at the same level as the range lows
and we are testing a support then I
might open a towards that level all
right so we're going to analyze this
again tomorrow but I want you to be
patient be patient like our friends
Henry Henry was patient and he didn't
lose money so the impatient Traders the
open shorts here they go stopped out
they end up losing money okay so
patience is very important be like Henry
guys anyway thank you Henry and thank
you you all for watching I'll see you
soon